hello war and who are coming to this
video playing hair stay off + 859 one
okay I'm trying out again this Bishop c5
line 85 90 10 and it's probably the
right way to pronounce it well you know
you we don't know but I don't know what
feels kind of logical okay so he got the
bishop habit in return I should have
very fluent development here Bishop g4
and so on so let's develop this and yeah
it's a position i like that looks very
harmonious that can never ever be bad
for black with this kind of
centralization going on okay that's the
point I don't know and stats cover first
and I could to be too right okay I do my
dad Oh am I not winning the colony to
its no idea cannot cannot trap cannot
track life resides very early
resignation here wow it's pretty awful
but still and they I want to do with the
game like that tell ya cancel I think
going to publish it i think there is one
point that's kind of interesting here
this night a4 move it's an interesting
question what to do with this this
bishop I can definitely move it let go
here so then if he likes you can take on
b6 but I felt like this is not such a
big deal i mean here those points they
have a very nice central control
and okay it's got the pair of bishops
which is not something that I like to
give my opponent but I have fantastic
central control I mean I just these
these moves are all very very natural
route the eight next and on move 12 here
I've got a yeah ideal kind of
development very active very very
centralized so that it looks very nice
this is I don't know this is probably
not such a great idea and after 94 I'm
not quite sure what is supposed to play
the engine wants to take with the bishop
of this kind of position and then query
em now black is a bit more comfortable
here is because of the EP file this is
even an idea trying to go there that
looks comfortable definitely comfortable
for black and but okay here he gave me
that and pawn bishop jakes is given by
the engine actually maybe this is indeed
stronger threatening here and he and go
go back yeah you can but very early very
early way to resign I think this Bishop
c5 line this one is a good is a good
practical weapon because it's it's
relatively easy to play and there are no
big pitfalls I think just develop
naturally okay well thanks for watching